so hello everyone thanks for joining I'm
going to talk to you a little bit about
the implementation of genome sequencing
as a clinical genetic diagnostic service
within our laboratory here at the lab
for molecular medicine part of the
partners healthcare so just quickly
before I go on just as a quick
disclosure this presentation discusses
gene insight which is a software that
we've developed that has been licensed
by partners healthcare and totally owned
one hundred percent by powers out there
so in general the laboratory testing
workflow is is something I'm sure all of
you are fairly familiar with but the the
test will will come in or will be
ordered by the by the doctor and by the
genetic counselor the case will come
into the laboratory will be accessioned
by the laboratory DNA will be extracted
or RNA depending on with the actual
tests that's being ordered and there'll
be some sort of wet lab processing the
technical component of the actual assay
the case management of that whole entire
essay and actually understanding sort of
what tests were being ordered from this
source sample that came in um any
bioinformatics processes that are
actually a component of the wet lab
technical components would then be run
the variants that were identified would
be pulled out need to then be curated by
the by the experts at the laboratory by
fellow genetic counselors variants
scientists geneticist pathologist
whoever might be Kate's would end up
being drafted and signed out and the
report be delivered back to the
clinician so this is a general sort of
laboratory testing workflow and for
genome and exome sequencing it's really
not that different I'm although there
are a few sort of caveats and specific
differences that that they're useful to
point out so in general a similar sort
of thing happens where the the patient
workup consented test odor comes through
you also then have the phenotype and
family history capture so for something
like genome and exome sequencing oxley
this end up being a lil
bit more important because sort of
casting a wider net and you need to have
ability to start focusing on the
variants that might be relevant for
specific phenotypes and sowing having a
more detailed phenotype and family
history capture methods obviously one
important component in addition I'll
touching this little later the consent
process is actually very important for
genome sequencing for both sort of the
the general sort of clinical consent but
also for the idea of incidental findings
and potential research from negative
cases once the sequencing is done um
there's an additional need to sort of
enrich the annotations of these variants
because there may be filtration
strategies that are necessary so really
before you do the manual analysis of
identifying variants that are important
for potentially important or relevant
for this particular case need to have
some sort of automated way to really
enrich these variants and then filtered
down on these variants oh this is sort
of a something that's slightly more
unique in the exome and genome realm
that's not necessarily considered
usually in the target realm you still
will then have the manual analysis would
determine the interpretation these
variants any sort of confirmation of
variants that you identify they're going
to put on the report and in addition for
for genome sequencing an exome
sequencing you'll have some time to
actually have more than one report so
you don't just have the sort of initial
report that is targeted for this sort of
primary indication for the test is being
ordered but you may have an additional
sort of incidental findings report which
well touch on at the end of the the talk
and finally although it's great if all
genetic testing end up sort of in the
EHR and can be used for clinical
decision support sort of the which the
vast amount of variance you get for
genomic sequencing it's actually in a
sense use more important to make sure
that data gets in there because there's
a lot more sort of clinical decision
support rules and longitudinal support
for the patient that you can sort of
gather from genome and exome sequencing
so this is a quick sort of overview I'm
sure everyone here knows a lot about XM
ng-conf genome sequencing but exome
sequencing really it's just sort of a
targeted type of sequencing so it is
still involves capture of specific
regions here you're sort of capturing
what you're considering the the X home
it's important to remember though that
exomes actually sort of Barry and in
what is the definition of an exome so it
may or may not include the five prime
and three prime UTR regions of the genes
it may or may not include micro RNAs and
it may or may not include unannotated
transcripts and so the way you define a
Texoma actually could be different
depending upon how a certain clinical a
bar or other lab actually wants you to
find their XO in addition there's really
still not one set of what an exome even
is and so if we look at some of the some
of the actual sources where you might
get excellent excellent information from
sound like rusty and sambal UCSC or this
consensus c.d.s effort which is sort of
a grouping of those three efforts you
can see that there's different numbers
of genes it varies widely as well as
different number of transcripts and so
depending upon which route you actually
choose you may actually have again a
different definition of what to be
wrexham is so it's important just to
remember that exomes differ between
potentially different between different
laboratories genome sequencing on the
other hand doesn't involve capture so
there's it's a shotgun based sequencing
method so there's a little less bias in
what is actually being sequenced however
it is important to remember genome
sequencing sort of like exome sequencing
isn't necessarily whole genome
sequencing and so today I'm only about
2.9 Giga bases of the 3.12 little big
bases actually have the fine sequence so
the telomeres and centimeters don't have
any fine sequence in addition when
you're going through a genome sequencing
typically 95% completeness at say 30 or
50 x coverages Islam is where you'll end
up getting but that's even not the case
and there's some systematics or a
dropout but it also could be random drop
out for between different samples of
what is actually covered in one genome
sequencing asset to the next one so just
as a quick comparison um genome vers
exome sequencing they both sort of have
benefits and caveats like I said there's
less bias in genome sequencing and so
you actually like it more completeness
of the exome depending on how things are
actually targeted
how our exome sequencing by its nature
because it's much more limited focused
you can get actually higher coverage on
average and so you tend to actually have
the ability to identify more true
positive variants that are just not
covered as well in genome sequencing
also there's still a cost differential
between exome and genome sequencing so
sort of the estimated reagent costs
today are approximately two thousand
dollars for exome sequencing this is
sort of give or take a little bit may
maybe a little less now and you can pool
probably two to four samples per hi-c
Clank dirt or to get pretty good
coverage for it for your exome
sequencing genome sequencing on the
other hand is maybe in the four to five
thousand dollar range for the reagent
cost and you actually need to use one
full flow cell in order to actually
capture enough of the sequence to get
high enough coverage one important
caveat to remember though is that this
doesn't include necessary computational
power mattox costs or the personnel
costs so the personnel costs would
actually probably be similar between the
two approaches today however the
computational cost the storage and the
compute time is actually still much
greater in genome sequencing it'll get a
little bit into the numbers from our
genome sequencing in a couple slides so
the cost per genome sequencing I know
everyone has seen this slide before but
this is sort of the average cost per
genome sequencing so the amount of
dollars it takes to actually complete a
full genome and one of the things that
that we were thinking of when we decided
to launch our test which actually wasn't
in 2011 was that we decided to choose
genome sequencing as our first primary
program and exome sequencing because of
the limitations of exome sequencing at
the time the more completeness of genome
sequencing and also because the costs
were coming down but as you can see the
costs haven't yet quite continue to drop
in 2012-2013 that's a sort of more
flatlined and so the actual cost
difference between exome genome
sequencing is still relevant today as
what it was a couple years ago and so
there's still higher cost to do genome
sequencing so that's why we are
considering actually launching
additional exome sequencing in in
addition to what we're doing for Geno
sequencing nouns of service but this is
sort of a second-tier approach from from
whatever primary focuses which and
everything so genome sequencing in our
lab at the lab for molecular medicine so
initially testing is being done for sort
of the diagnostic context and in this
case will be returning primary
indication reports for for the actual
probe and we'll also have the option of
enabling in central findings reports and
at the end of the talking to go through
a lot more detail how we've actually
structured these reports so you can sort
of see how they're they're laid out in
our minds for full genome sequencing the
incidental findings report we have a
general genome report which cast a very
wide net for incidental findings which
is in our consent process come to be an
opt-out and also ACMG guidelines report
if someone decides to opt out of the
general genome report they have the
option of doing just the ACMG
recommended 27 diseases report um or
they have the option today is still not
getting any incidental findings report
if that's requested and really this is
going to be a phone call to want to
understand why people are choosing to do
maybe the full internal findings or the
limited incidental findings or actually
no into defining report so um testing
for healthy individuals we're actually
doing this today in the concept through
our collaboration with the med seek
study and I'll talk about that a little
bit at the end but we would be
interested in actually offering this for
healthy individuals but it is going to
depend upon the the Q of the sort of
diagnostic contest so anyone is doing it
or diagnostic contact would actually
have priority within our laboratory of
the post healthy individuals so why
would someone sort of come and get
genome sequencing again I'm sure
everyone has some similarities with this
today it's really not used for places
where there's a clear indication and
where there's a good targeted assay for
that test and so we really want people
to come in who maybe that maybe had
prior genetic testing but have not yet
found ideology for their disease or they
have sort of extreme phenotype this
no real clear way to create a unifying
diagnosis for what they have there's no
clear indication of a targeted test
approach first and the reason why we
would recommend that people get targeted
testing versus as I mentioned the
coverage and completeness of both exome
and genome sequencing today isn't yet
what we have for target sequencing and
so there's a the risk of actually
missing the true variant just because
the coverage aspect of the genes that
you're focusing in on might not be there
and then as I mentioned there is
potential for patients who have a desire
to inform the medical risk so there's
something that we would consider to
perform but it's sort of in the context
of all the other cases that would have
in a nose so this is sort of just
another view of the the whole genome
sequencing process and we use this sort
of as a guideline to take us through how
we've actually implemented genome
sequencing here the lmm so the first
thing happens is the case or gets
received next session within laboratory
and the technical component of genome
sequencing is performed so we've
actually created a simplified
requisition form which I'll show on the
next page I'm we're going to follow this
up with a phone call for gathering
detailed phenotypic information I'm
Charlie today it's a paper requisition
form but it's sort of modeled after
things like Pinot DB and Pinot tips and
so that way when we have the ability
when we finally implement some of those
systems that help us capture phenotypic
data more readily to actually be an easy
way to transition into one of those
additional forms obviously I
Massachusetts we need a clinical
consents of the clinical second sent
with the opt-in opt-out no with the opt
out of the incidental findings would be
included however there's an additional
thing to think about for genome
sequencing which is research consent so
internal samples here within partners we
actually would like to get a research
consent so we can have them available
for for bio banking purposes we're
trying to start a large we already have
a bio banking initiative but but even
make it a lot more fuller I'm and expand
beyond sort of the number of campbell's
that we have today and so this would be
a prime way to actually get additional
samples within the bio banking effort
and another unique thing sort of about
exome and genome sequencing in a way is
that because you've sort of already
capturing a lot of this data you may
have cases that you come in obviously a
lot of cases that will be negative or
inconclusive and being sort of part of a
broader research community here at
partners we have the ability to actually
form collaborations with with
researchers and sort of have a way to
sort of share cases that have similar
phenotypes and people can and then sort
of get together and have an exchange of
patients who have actually consented for
research in order to understand similar
cases that they may not be able to pull
together today and that way there's
ability for researchers to identify
multiple cases with similar phenotypes
and actually to attack those together
where they wouldn't have that
opportunity before so this is something
that that we'd also like to pursue for
some of our clinical cases to see if
they'd be interested in this sort of
deeper level of research consent to be
able to sort of tackle this in a broader
community effort so I'm not sure how
well people can see this so this is the
simplified requisition form that we have
sort of on the first page is a quick
overview of any clinical information
with sort of a rundown of primary
disease areas or primary anatomy areas
that someone can check whether it's
abnormal normal or unknown it's abnormal
tickets or type in some of the quick
findings for that specific area there's
also obviously exome and genome
sequencing in any actually genetic
testing family history is very important
so we won't be able to capture sort of
what other individuals within this
family have both in a family tree like
structure as well as sort of in a
tabular structure and the tabular
structure we are interested in knowing
who is potentially also available for
both full sequencing and Confirmation
sequencing so if we're interested in a
probe and its potential de novo case we
may have the parents to sequence and get
that information quicker maybe we only
sequence of probands and then actually
four variants that are interesting see
if they're actually de novo by looking
at the parents for just that specific
region so there's different ways that
you might actually capture sort of
a specific clinical case it's important
to know sort of what's types of samples
are actually involved and what sorry
what sort of samples are available for
testing it and depending upon who
actually defected are unaffected may
actually help you choose which samples
to actually do sequencing on so once the
sort of the cases accessioned and
processed in the laboratory that the
genome sequencing component is done and
it may be done within the lab it be done
external lab and brought in houses the
different ways you can actually do the
genome sequencing but once you sort of
have the raw data from the genome
sequencing it's important then to
obviously do the alignment variant
calling annotation all those sort of
specific aspects that you're going to do
with two to identify the variance within
the particular individual so what we've
done here is we have actually used a
modified version of bwa and gatk to sort
of help paralyzed or genome cases so on
average we're getting 600 million
paired-end reads proximately which is
about two hundred fifty gigabytes in
size for the actual compressed bam file
this is an average depth of
approximately 40 X with 95 completeness
95% completeness across the genome and
actually to to take the the bam file
that we get originally conferred it
convert it back to a fast queue then do
alignment over again and variant calling
we have this down for our genome
sequences to be about 28 hours so it's
obviously if someone's make the
implementing genome sequencing it's
important to know sort of how how long
it takes to really be able to actually
run one of these sequences through even
a modified pipeline be able to get it
down it's not a this is a fairly fast
turnaround time but it's still not as
fast as it may need to be for specific
use cases our current pipeline today
identifies snv's and small in dells it's
approximately five million variants
called this is before sort of quality
filtration metrics that we've
established within our laboratory for
specific pipeline sorted from the raw
calls we have a book five million
variants per sample that are called that
are just snps and or smaller
we then annotate these variants with
approximately hundred different features
and we include information from VEP
alamut which includes sort of
conservation measures and until ago
prediction tools and a few different
measures on ESP and thousand genomes and
other sort of population frequency data
sets and a few other data sets and so we
sort of take these these variants we've
identified do a very rich thorough
annotation process on them and then load
them into what we were calling sort of
our genetic data repository so genetic
data repository sort of contained all
the variants we've identified
individuals it contained them per
individual and contained a separate
table which is sort of the annotations
of all the days we've ever identified so
we have a quick way to sort of do
filtration and matching based upon sort
of generic features of the of the
different variants and I'll get into the
filtration and a couple sides but the
way we're able to enable our filtration
process is because we have sort of the
this rich set of annotation data within
our genomic data repository that we've
developed here so when you're doing any
sort of clinical genetic testing
obviously you need to validation of your
pipeline you need to validate that
you're actually getting what you're what
you think you're getting it so you need
you robustness testing as well as sort
of specificity and sensitivity testing
so the way we approach this we feel that
sort of identification of any variant is
similar whether or not it's benign of
pathogenic especially when you're doing
full sequencing you don't know most of
time what novel variants are actually
doing until you sort of do a deeper
curation even then they make the
appearance of unknown significance and
so the way we've tackled it is is by
sort of looking so globally our ability
to detect variation across a broad range
of sequence and so we actually have
pretty in-depth sequencing for 195 genes
which is approximately 700 kb of sequins
and this includes Sanger sequencing
sequencing by array and next-generation
sequencing for a lot of these different
at least two short different
technologies for all these different
hundred ninety five genes so we sort of
well characterized the variation that we
I
identified we can identify within the
700 kb of sequence and from that we
actually identified 425 variants that
we've confirmed via Sanger and other
methods within this data set 15 of which
were in Dale's 410 of which were snv's
and we were able to detect all these I'm
using our pipeline to determine that you
know we're actually identifying the
variant said that that we want to be
identifying based upon the coverage that
we're getting at these position we also
want to do a sensitivity analysis so
again within this sort of 700 kb of
sequence we want to identify any
variance that we called the next-gen
sequencing via whole genome sequencing
that wasn't called via or other
technologies and we had 20 false
positive smbs and one false positive in
dell and when we further characterized
and looked more deeply into these
specific regions we understood that we
could actually apply some sort of
quality metrics to limit the the false
positive barrington we're identifying so
when we then went ahead and applied our
quality metrics so a fisher strand
strand bias fisher metric less than 30
so this is one of the outputs you can
get from gatk as well as a quality by
depth score we were able to use these
two fairly simple quality metrics we
actually we're able to thoroughly reduce
the amount of false-positive variance
that we've identified and in practice
today this this still holds true we when
we use our quality metrics we actually
have a fairly limited number of false
positive variants we more probably get
is actually Paul sanitation calls so
something is called sort of a frameshift
when it's actually two frame ships next
to each other and it's actually sort of
a three base pair in frame deletion or
something like that so so most of the
time any discrepancies we get are
actually based upon the annotations
today and not necessarily based on false
positive variation we also wanted to do
concordance results obviously thousand
genomes data is a great data set to look
at oh it's hard to determine which of
these would actually be the gold
standards we want to see what
concordance rate was with variants
called via thousand genomes and so when
we went through that process we actually
had a fairly high concordance rate
especially for single nucleotide
variants across the entire genome so we
actually had 99% of calls that were
present within thousand genomes were
also present within our genome
sequencing for smbs and ninety-one
percent concordance with in dell calls
across the the the two datasets um there
was when we looked at sort of variance
with mass genotypes of a hat versus
ahead so we called it a head and cough
genomes called it a head or we called
homozygous variant on genomes called it
a homozygous variant we still had very
high concordance rate it dropped a
little bit as would be expected but it's
actually good so reassurance that the
variants that were calling seem to be
identified via via other methods as well
so so once you've sort of gone through
the whole process and you you've
identified the full set and full range
of variants that you've seen from your
genome sequencing or exome sequencing
case the next step really is to target
to filter these variants because it's
slightly different obviously that then a
targeted panel the way we approach our
target testing is we actually manually
interpret every single variant that we
identify within the target region and we
associate all those sort of with the
case in in some sort of framework from
saved a 92 to pathogenic however with XO
mean genome sequencing it's not
technically possible actually to or
physically possible to actually do this
manual trepidation of all hundred
thousand or five million bearings
whatever you get for the different
technologies and so you actually need a
way to sort of filter down based upon
both sort of the phenotype and the
genetics due to a more limited set of
variants that would then go on for the
sort of to the manual filtration steps
so this is sort of one general way you
can think about how filtration metrics
might be performed in the calm approach
of genome sequencing and so you have
your whole whole genome sequencing
which identifies the millions of
variants you may then look for sort of
things that are novel or low frequency
variants so in the context of sort of
rare disorders or in dealing in
inherited conditions obviously we're
looking for things that are are more
rare in the context of common disease
you may be looking for more common
variants but since we're mostly focused
on sort of rare rare disorders and
dealing disorders we actually want to
focus on limited to sort of but not
novel and low frequency variants I'm so
using things like ESP and then thousand
genomes for different populations we
actually then may depending upon our
knowledge and our ability to interpret
limit this to sort of variants that are
in gene or non coding or conserved
regions from there you want to look at
things that have actually then be
associated the disease that you're
interested in so the individual comes in
with specific phenotypes or specific
diagnosis you may want to first first
pastor limited to to the genes and
diseases within that context you then
would then obviously do look at the
variants that are predictably pathogenic
maybe their loss of function and jeans
are known to have lots of function
variants their previously reported in
other databases or there's actual sort
of manual curation to get that or other
metric methods to sort of identify
parents that might be pathogenic you
then do manual curation to see if
there's anything that is actually
relevant one of the sort of interesting
things about genome and exome sequencing
is there's this probably need to do an
iterative process for some cases so in
cases where it's sort of inconclusive or
negative you may then sort of me to
broaden the net wider to be able to
identify more variants that should go
through this pipeline it and then
through the manual curation one of the
tricky things is to identify when it's
appropriate to stop here so so when you
actually have a negative case and that's
one of the things that is obviously
challenging into context of genome and
exome sequencing is that what stage you
end up reporting sort of a negative or
inconclusive finding finally you're
you're probably identifying in the range
of five to ten variants or maybe a zero
that you actually end up on the final
report things that you've thoroughly in
festa gated you've been able to sort of
associate clinical significance and it
has some relevance to the patient's
phenotype and these are what may end up
sort of on the final report that gets
delivered to the clinician so some
general approaches to filtration
obviously everyone may have some
experience with this and there's
different things that you may do so if
you're looking for spragg disorders you
may want to identify the novo variants
usually this is a much easier approach
if you have just one or two per exone
obviously you need to have the parental
sequences here as well so so there's
some issues with with cost analysis of
identifying the the cost for something
that may be de novo is it worth sort of
doing the parents right away and then
just filtering down to those ones that
you know dinovo or sit actually is that
actually less expensive than sort of
doing the filtration on the child first
and then doing sang a confirmation of
the additional variants so there's sort
of a cost-benefit analysis for doing the
parents as well as the individual in
this case I'm recessive disorders is
equal you're looking for gene that has
sort of rare by allelic variants
obviously when you have multiple
affected siblings the power to detect
needs would actually increase for
cantankerous families you may search for
rare homozygous variants could you're
expecting actually to be a more
homozygous variant that is that is
causing the phenotype Dom disorders can
tend to be the trickiest but you may
then have the ability to identify
distantly related cousins I mean have
those be to people that end up being
sequence and so then have the ability to
narrow down to two specific variants
that are shared among distantly affected
individuals in cancer sort of doing a
filtration where you compare somatic
versus germline results you can identify
those variants that are specifically
occurring within the tumor so the way
that we're approaching this obviously
we're we're actually returning to
reports as I mentioned earlier and I'm
going to go into a little bit more
detail in a second but for our
infiltration the primary indication
filtration is really based upon like I
said the combination of genetics and
indication do we think it's recessive do
you think its dominant you think it's de
novo and also what the actuals phenotype
is and so we limit it down to a
instead of jeans so we've developed sort
of a method here of our gene panel
selection where we actually have the
ability to go in and and focus on or try
to identify the variants that are at a
first-tier sort of highly likely to be
relevant to this phenotype or disease
and maybe that second tier so genes that
are related in different pathways or
have expression data that might suggest
that they're also related to this
potential phenotype or disease and from
here we also created sort of a web
database link to to help us with this
gene panel selection tool for anything
that's known today of sort of gene
disease phenotype relationships and so
basically on the phenotypes that were
getting and potentially diseases that
we're getting good ability to do a first
pass on our genes that may be relevant
for that particular phenotype and then
our general genome filtration this is
our expanded incidental findings report
and so really what we're looking for is
variants have been previously
characterized as disease-causing in
available databases predicted
loss-of-function variants within the
medical exilim and again because we're
we're doing the sort of in the Mendelian
context we're looking at variants that
are less than a five percent
subpopulation minor allele frequencies
so we can limit the scope of things that
we actually end up doing manual
adjustment on so I'm going to go go
through these two reports a little bit
later on in the presentation but this is
sort of the way that we're thinking
about the filtration profits um so so
the various Essman process this is
really when you determine the level of
or when you determine sort of the
category the classification of this
particular variant related to specific
diseases so obviously there there's a
few different ways to do this you want
to gather as many sources you can as I
mentioned before we have approximately
100 different annotations we have on the
variance and then what we do is we go
through this very manual process we have
to look at specific variants in more
detail so this includes sort of looking
at different publicly available
databases such as clinvar I'm dmu DB
from the UK and an effort that I'm
involved in with with bringing in sort
of variants within the Canadian labs are
sort of Canadian bear
Arians or variants identified in
Canadian laboratories and having a
centralized incidence for those so
different sources of clinically
interpreted disease variances is
obviously a little higher grade than
sort of things that are reported
pathogenic in the literature then do a
very end assessment so it's a thorough
review of over these hundred different
features and we haven't expanded this
this very thorough Excel template of
shells I'll show quickly in the next
slide that um that we actually make
available for other people to use if
they're interested which helps us
actually determine on the classic gather
all the data and help determine sort of
the classification for these particular
variants related to specifically because
I'm one unique thing sort of about
genome sequencing that that we actually
hadn't had a Crowder before is usually
when you do targeted sequencing you
actually have a clear definition of
genes that are associated to diseases
and their strength of association before
you start or else you wouldn't
necessarily include them on your
targeted essay you do include them you
know that they're very strongly
associated Z's or they have mild
association disease however when you
start doing genome and exome sequencing
one of the important things is you
actually end up getting these genes and
diseases that you actually don't know
sort of what the clinical phenotype is
so this is actually need to sort of do
gene assessments um at the start or as
soon as variants are identified so it's
a unique paradigm shift for up for us
where we actually then have to identify
variants and then go back and see okay
we identified this variant that someone
said was was pathogenic but is that gene
really even associated with disease or
not so that's something that is sort of
new at our laboratory and actually one
of the other geneticists in our
laboratory Barry funk is actually doing
this in in collaboration with midori
have a Emory and avni sub teeny at chop
to actually look at what we're calling
the medical exome and actually using a
community effort to go ahead and sort of
tackle the the genes that we know have
some my association with disease and
actually be able to rank those and and
see how strongly we can say that they're
associated specific diseases and so that
time when you actually get a variant and
one of these diseases a lot easier to
see okay what is the real
evidence for this gene Disease
Association so this is just a quick
snapshot of one of the pages for our
very assessment this is we have like an
18 tab excel file that we go through
manually for a specific variant to
determine the clinical relevance to
disease when the process of sort of
modifying this all the time and so it's
becoming a lot more user-friendly and a
lot more nicer to actually navigate
through this is something that if
anyone's interested we actually be
willing to share and sort of help other
people sort of go through this process
and then how we're thinking about or the
clinical variant assessment piece of our
interpretation process so once we have
identified variants again we start with
the 325 million variants we apply the
filters we do this manual assessment we
then sort of bend them in a Mendelian
world into sort of benign likely benign
be us likely pathogenic or pathogenic
and one different things sort of a
genome and exome sequencing is is
previously we've really associate every
variant we identify with the report
however today there's there's so many
more variance is so many variants we
don't need classifieds they don't meet
filtrations surgeries or things we
classified likely benign or v us and so
actually what ends up on the report in
the sort of genome and Exum world in our
laboratory is actually going to be
pathogenic and likely pathogenic
variants and a subset of variants of
unknown significance which really seem
to be associated with the phenotype or
have a much stronger correlation of
potentially being associated with a
phenotype so it really is a slightly
different paradigm for our laboratory
and how we're actually going about
actually reporting these these cases um
the the other paradigm shift in our
laboratory is previously we actually do
confirmation of all variants that are
going to end up on the reports all
pathogenic and be us and likely
pathogenic variants what we did in the
past is is in targeted testing to
include every variant we do our
confirmation before we actually do the
assessment process we've actually had a
switch this sort of to to save costs and
time we actually do the assessment first
and then actually go and do the variant
confirmation and the reason for this is
is for most things in genome and exome
sequencing we actually haven't yet
identified the the cases previously
these regions previously and so we've
never actually looked at them so we'd
actually don't have
primers for our grand confirmation
process and so we actually want to limit
it to the thing that we're most likely
end up on the report and sort of do our
assessment process first and then go
forward with the confirmation process so
it's a shift in sort of how we actually
do things today in our laboratories and
so it creates this sort of need to
develop an automated primer design
pipeline we were calling primer design
on the fly so it actually increases the
varying efficiency within our laboratory
and enable starts to turn around time
because now when we sort of identify
something that we need to confirm we can
throw it into this pipeline develop
design the primers efficiently and
quickly and actually go in order them
and bring them back and so this actually
isn't saving some time and helping our
turnaround time for our genome cases and
currently today for confirmation were
since we're identifying snv's and small
in dells we're using Sanger confirmation
sequencing but as our sort of
capabilities to call variants expands we
have the ability to also bring in TD pcr
for sort of smaller copy number variants
as well as using a genotyping array to
actually look at larger copy number and
LOH changes and so sort of the the way
we actually do varying confirmation is
going to slightly shift as our
capabilities of calling variants shift
and this is shows the importance of sort
of having it's a case management system
which allows you to sort of link
together the different technology that
you're using for confirmation and the
different primary assays and be able to
reconcile any differences between the
different technologies that you're using
to look for variants so once sir you
have the variants you've identified that
you wanted then proceeded with four
genome and exome sequencing this is when
the you should have dropped the case and
put into the context for this individual
and do the signup process so I'm going
to talk a little bit more detail about
both of our primary indication report
and a primary indication report is sort
of the is based on the model that we
used for the clarity from the clarity
challenge i'm not sure everyone is
familiar with the clarity challenge but
it was last year sponsored by by
Children's Hospital in Boston and really
what it was is a way to develop sort of
clinical pipelines and reporting
structures for genome and exome
sequencing cases
and we r group work pretty closely with
the Brigham and Women's Hospital
genetics group instead of defining the
pipeline and defining sort of the
structure of the report and our full
team won and a lot of the reason why we
won was the structure of our sort of
genome report and what we were able to
return to the clinician we've also then
developed a general genome report which
is again is our incidental findings
report and this is what we're using for
the med seek project the message project
is a large you'll one project that is
spearheaded by Robert Greene um here at
the Brigham and what it is is really
looking at both individuals with disease
and healthy individuals and giving them
back genome findings and seeing sort of
how the doctors on both primary care
clinicians and and specialists actually
deal with sort of the scope of genome
data and actually identify sort of the
outcomes and anything that they may do
differently based upon the the reports
that they're getting back and so this is
um the first sort of targeted approach
that we're taking and so I'm going to go
through a little bit more detail how
we're structuring those reports as well
um and then for for drafting and sign up
we actually use our in-house gene inside
software which enables us to sort of
create templates and create temples in
the process to enable efficiency in our
drafting process and so based upon the
variants identified and very easily sort
of draft a case on both our Intel
findings report and our primary
indication report and actually have this
be able to be much more limited in the
time it takes for our genetic counselors
and our geneticists actually go through
and drafting them for complex reports
and also all of our confirmed
interpreted variants are associated the
case of gene insight and as well as our
interpretations so it much more easily
enables the the flow of this information
into gene insight and into our reports
as well as the dissemination of this
information to effort like clinvar and
other laboratories who are sharing data
with so so the creation of the genome
reporting process obviously these are
very complex on that can be ambiguous
they could potentially be lengthy
there's a risk of sort of doing any
misinterpretation of the relevant
results and there also could be the
because of
they're complex nature could impede the
incorporation of genomic data into
clinical care so these are some of the
things you need to think about when
you're creating sort of genome report
formats so you want to be able to create
reports that are effectively and
efficiently communicate the data to the
clinicians into their patients he'll
provide insight to sort of future health
reproductive risks and enable the
physician to sort of take those next
appropriate steps so this is a quick
view of our our primary indication
report it's it's tech space today but
obviously a a lot of things may need to
change into a sort of more table format
to really produce this information in a
much clearer manner but really the first
thing that we focus on is identifying or
just listing the the most likely
relevant variants oh these are the
variants that we identified in this case
this is there um the actual the actual
variants we've seen this is how we're
classifying it today within the
laboratory and if possible if you
actually have this information
particularly for de novo cases and
recessive cases you may have the ability
to sort of indicate the parental
inheritance which which oftentimes is
very useful in going through these cases
um that's sort of the first layouts we
have the overall result and sort of what
that means for this particular
individual and this with specific
phenotype they're being tested for um
once you have lists of variants you can
sort of do an overall summary of what
you're looking at so one of the things
that's important to know is is for
something like this where they have this
individual had a clear phenotypes and
one of the first things we want to look
at is the genes that are associated this
phenotype and knowing both if we
identified any variance but also that
the limitations and so knowing that for
these genes actually a certain
percentage of the coding regions
actually wasn't able to be interpreted
and so there may actually be sort of
rare pathogenic variants that are
missing within those cases and so it's
important to be able to let the the
clinicians know what the limitations are
for the specific in general but also for
the specific genes that you're focusing
on for a particular case um and then
sort of you can do an analysis of or
just look at my snow ice what the
Barents you've identified are and how
they sort of correspond to the
particular phenotype you're identifying
and there's a chance for
Chanel bearing to identify maybe you
thought this might be a de novo case you
can sort of say other variants that
you've ruled out because of different
metrics that didn't meet the criteria to
be included on the report so you can
sort of add that information as well in
the interpretation summary then the way
we structure the report is we list the
variance we have the overall summary
that that's clear and laid out for the
clinician but then if they want the
additional detail they have the ability
to come in here and and see sort of the
detailed variant interpretation so
really the evidence for why our
laboratory is calling this a likely
pathogenic variant and Titan why we're
calling this one uncertain significance
but but favoring pathogenic variant
within Titan as well and so you can
actually see the detailed evidence
around why we're classifying variants in
particular metrics so that's the the
primary indication report again we're
also returning a general genome report
which is an expanded incidental findings
report that we helped develop with the
med seed project so the way we've wanted
to develop this is sort of have a
one-page summary of the important
findings for this particular individual
and then have more detailed information
in the next pages where they can
actually dive in and see the reason for
classification and what this really
means for the their patient so the
filtration metrics that we're doing for
general gene report this is sort of a
potential scenario is one example where
you have say over 3 million snps you
have 500,000 in dells you limit this to
genes I me have a much smaller number
that are within the coding sequence it
was flight sighs variants look for
things are reported in variant databases
as disease-causing you do sort of the
more rare finding so you limited based
upon frequency and then you look for
sort of novel loss-of-function variants
and the novel loss-of-function variants
or rare lost a bunch of variants within
what we're calling this medical exilim
again this is the the list of genes that
we've curated that we really think have
some potential relevance to disease and
sort of from this filtration you may get
a few pathogenic variants here a few
pathogenic variants from this method
then we're also actually including
pharmacogenomic variants that we're
looking at specifically to determine and
so there's an additional set of variants
for the pharmacogenomic effect so this
is sort of the way that you would limit
it based upon the filtration strategies
and then the manual assessment of the
variants and then so what we want to do
again it is sort of develop a way to to
deliver this all those findings into a
simple single page report and so the way
we structured it is we actually start
sort of with an overall finding to the
reports and we say that say ninety-eight
percent of the genome was covered and we
called four million variants or whatever
it is and then we get into a little bit
more detail where we say for anything
that sort of a monogenic disease risk so
variants that are sort of inheriting it
in a more dominant fashion or
potentially two recessive variants
within the same gene we actually have
the ability we lay out for the clinician
the disease that that's important with
its inheritance pattern the phenotype
that is just sort of the initial
phenotype the one that they should know
about that's important for this
particular disease are the behringer's
identified as well as our overall
classification we do this term relief
for anything we identify this potential
carrier risk one thing that we also add
for this table is often some of these
things can have sort of carrier
phenotypes and so it's important to be
able to list what the potential carrier
phenotypes may be so here we have the
ability to say that for CF this variant
is is pathogenic for CF and their
carrier that but there's also a risk of
infertility for male patient with
someone is carrying this CF variant and
so you can add additional sort of
carrier phenotypes to this report on
this through initial page summary that
the doctors looking at also for this
we're looking at sort of five
pharmacogenomic sort of not nesting
variants of five pharmacogenomic effects
and so as a quick snapshot of sort of
what is being done for these
pharmacogenomic associations and what
this means for their the particular
patient and including the the different
dosage requirements or anything any risk
that they have
because of the Barents are identified so
this is sort of the first page overview
that we have of the report then you have
the ability to get into a little bit
more details so again this is sort of
similar what you saw on the primary
indication report illus late a little
bit more tabular of specific information
about the disease if we have the
prevalence if we have sort of any
variant frequency of this the
interpretation which is why we're
calling this variant in this case
pathogenic for episodic ataxia as well
as some disease information and and risk
for the family and you can sort of go
through this in the different sections
we have sort of more detailed
information for the pharmacogenomic
variants and then obviously the
methodology and limitation that they
mentioned for our are incredibly
important and so here sort of
methodology important both for the
incidental findings and for the full
primary indication report it's important
to note sort of what our minimum quality
metrics are both for variant calling as
well for the genome as a whole what the
filtration strategies we use in this
particular case are in order to get down
to the variant we've identified and also
what the inclusion criteria what very
interaction including on this report and
which ones aren't so the actually one
risk of potentially including something
that says the u.s. likely pathogenic is
the clinician might assume that all
variants of unknown significance that
you're identified are included but
obviously that's not the case is pretty
much every very end to the very
dependent significance so actually being
able to say exactly what variants were
actually including on this final report
is very important in addition the
limitations is is important particularly
for the the test that we're doing and
understanding let me finish know that
the different aspects of genome
sequencing so first of all genome
sequencing is not whole genome
sequencing that there's obviously the
ability as I mentioned in the earlier in
the talk of we don't know what the whole
genome is and there's difficulty
identifying variants with with
additional regions such as repeat
expansion translocations RCMP's we can't
identify all variants just because we're
not technically looking for CNVs and
translocations at this moment in time to
being able to really say with the
limitations of the particular SAR also
knowing that that
all variants are actually interpreted
some of them just use sort of these
filtration metrics to get to I'm
variants we have the ability to do more
manual interpretation on we also don't
know all the disease gene associations
and so it's important to remember that
not everything we're looking at we can
even interpret today and there's the
ability to actually reinterpret things
in the future that's going to be very
important um and also just in general
variation and jeans is still not well
understood similar to the the chain of
these associations doesn't really well
understood and as I mentioned a second
ago the really the need to reinterpret
genome data because the field is
evolving so quickly and the clinical
knowledge of the genomes evolving so
quickly that there is a need to actually
do this third reinterpretation of the
genome even for the the internal
findings report and for primary
indication reports and are able to let
the clinician know what the certain
newest evidence levels are for four
different variants are identified so
finally once you have the reports are
see it's important to deliver them to
the Commission we're using here within
partners our gene and psych clinic
software which is embedded within our
EHR so for anyone who actually is
ordering locally from us within our
institution we actually are sending the
reports directly to the students at
clinic instance within our EHR and
actually helps us deliver these more
structured PDF reports and not just hl7
based text ah hl7 based sort of test
reports which enables us to really give
this much more structured view with like
you see in the general genome report and
I just showed you it also tracks sort of
the report has been reviewed and also
alerts that I've interviewed not I'll
touch on the alerts in the next slide
and as I mentioned sort of we have this
sort of in conjunction with their EHR
although there is the opportunity to
have this sort of a standalone piece of
software and so really what it enables
is is sending of the report to the
clinician for genome sequencing they may
have a few more variants that they've
identified here the ability to sort of
look at the full report ability to look
at the parents are identified what the
reported category was but importantly
actually what the current category was
because I mentioned before genetic
knowledge 'used is changing rapidly all
the time it's important to be able to
alert the clinician when that knowledge
has changed so we've set up the system
so when the variant gets reinterpreted
within the laboratory so say I'm the
geneticist and I'm signing out a case um
and actually see a variant that I've
seen before and there's new evidence now
to suggest that it's not a V us actually
katha genic and i make that change any
previous individual that had that
variant with the clinician would be
alerted that has been a classification
change within that particular variant so
if you you see here you can initially
this variant with was reported as
pathogenic however back in March of 2013
we reinterpreted this variant and now
calling it pathogenic and so the
punishment have the ability to come and
see this if they click on that link to
get to sort of more detailed information
again that evidence section of why we're
calling the variant pathogenic for this
particular disease and so because the
the field of genome sequencing and all
clinical testing is rapidly evolving we
found it important and necessary to
create sort of a somewhat automated way
of alerting our clinicians when we have
new knowledge and when it may be
relevant for four different treatment
decision for the particular patients so
this is a way for us to deliver that
knowledge to them so with that I just
want to wrap up again and go through the
genome sequencing process again it's
really similar to to what is being done
in lab today although that does have it
it's it's arm specific points in in
caveats that are important to remember
so the the phenotype is particularly
important Organa per genome sequencing
the consent process and and whether or
not you actually go for research consent
as well is very important I'm sort of
the idea between enrichment filtration
and manual analysis and doing all that
first and then going and confirming the
variant I'm in terming work it's on the
report and then the sort of the idea of
having multiple different reports in
multiple different layouts of reports
sort of associated with a particular
case and finally the the need to sort of
do the reinterpretation and the alerting
to clinicians as well as you need to get
these variants into the EHR to enable
longitudinal support and clinical
decision support
so with that I'd like to wrap up and
take any questions I want to obviously
thank everyone who's worked on this here
within our laboratory and across the the
Med seek project and food the other
collaborations that we have obviously
this is sort of a short lift as then
many many people involved in this effort
to get genome sequencing launched within
our laboratory and with that I just want
to take any questions I see that there
are some questions already and also I
want to mention that for the continuing
education credits make sure you you log
on to the bio conference live website to
the CME section feel to to get the
continuing education credits for this
exam of course um so I'm going to try to
go through some of these questions
anyone else is in additional questions
please feel free to to to Ford leaves
along so I see that there are some
questions if anyone's interested in
using sort of the spreadsheet that I
mentioned for our novel bearing
assessment today feel free to email me
my email is M le Bo at partners org and
I'd be happy to send that along and sort
of with an SOP that we've developed in
order to sort of work through that
process um someone mention asked what
the cost of a case for us is and so it
costs today for us to do sort of genome
sequencing for an individual is nine
thousand dollars we have the ability
also if someone has previously had their
sequencing done in a CLIA lab using
alumina technologies that we have the
ability to do that interpretation
process at a much more limited cost of
five thousand dollars we don't actually
have to do the technical component we
actually have the ability to sort of
someone else asked if we had ability to
work with international tables we do
international samples today so we'd be
happy to accept any sort of
international samples for a case as well
I should also mention sort of in the
cost of genome sequencing right now we
it's nice out dolls for single genome
for a trio it is eighteen thousand
dollars and and we can help work with
individuals for any sort of combination
of
people for sequencing that that makes
sense for that low spaces also for sort
of having the family members available
that's sort of including the cost for
for some of these interpretations as
well so so for the the fill a couple of
questions that I'm looking at right now
um someone asked if they understand
correctly for the first several steps
based on are based on prior knowledge
and how best case how to identify novel
mutations and so it's not necessarily
based upon prior knowledge for for
internal findings report we are using
both variants have been previously
identified as well as novel
loss-of-function variants in what we're
calling this medical exum however for
sort of the primary indication report
where we're going to look at sort of all
variants that meet certain criteria
based on my genetics and gene Disease
Association and look at those variants
and be able to rank those and do manual
assessment to identify which ones may be
the most relevant for particular sort of
interpretations
alright so and so someone else asked for
varying confirmation obviously the
functional knowledge of the pathway it
requires at some point functional
knowledge of the pathway for which a
gene is given so for genes which there
are functional tests you confirm
Darren's using traditional biochemical
or molecular base a phase so
unfortunately in a lot of clinical
laboratories they're not necessarily set
up to actually do functional testing as
well obviously one of the benefits of
potentially working with researchers is
the ability to if we identify novel
variation to establish and we have such
a good network here within Partners
Health help here to be able to sort of
set up collaborations with researchers
to help them do sort of functional
assays for specific variants and then we
can maybe have a little bit more to say
on novel variants in it and sort of what
the relationship is disease but from a
traditional sort of clinical lab
approach it's just really not within our
scope of expertise to be able to do that
sort of more traditional functional
assays and so it is much more limiting
so it is one of those opportunities as
mentioned to sort of work with
researchers to be able to to get
variants interpreted more thoroughly
based on functional data that functional
data is a very important way to help us
classify variants so someone asked how
many man-hours are involved in report
and how do we deal with the fact that
the genes are poorly annotated and the
single gene has many entries in ncbi so
obviously this is this is one limitation
of genome sequencing and in part of the
reason for the increased cost of it is
the amount of manual interpretation that
has to be done and so on average when we
do a novel daring assessment it takes
about 20 minutes for or a little less
than 20 minutes for variants that have
no knowledge however by its nature when
we're looking at variants that have
previous knowledge there's a lot more
literature and so these ones can take
from up to a half an hour to two hours
depending upon the amount of literature
for variant and so that's why the the
manual filtration step is incredibly
important because we don't have the
ability to actually go through so go
through these all manually so doing that
filtration process to get down to the
smaller set of variants because
incredibly important to genome
sequencing just because of the sort of
the man-hours it costs in order to do
sort of the manual assessment of the
branch which is really the probably the
most time-consuming piece today for
genome sequencing for it for hands-on
components I think I might have time for
for one more question so so someone
asked if methylation filtration might
reduce the cost of sequencing today we
we don't do sort of methylation
sequencing so so I think there's ways to
sort of bring that information in and
limit the scope of things that we end up
sequencing but it's not something that
we actually offer today and again for
anyone who is interested my email again
is M le be 0 at partners org so m and
then libo is my last name f-harness are
over so thank you um